sound the alarms according to comments
from an executive at EA it appears that
Mass Effect Andromeda will not be
released in 2016 as previously indicated
I'm Lucy and welcome to this renegade
gamespot news update speaking in an
interview at a business summit EA chief
financial officer Blake Jorgensen said
the highly anticipated sequel will be
available in q4 in the context of his
comments he appears to be referring to
the fiscal fourth quarter and not the
calendar fourth quarter ea's financial
fourth quarter stretches across January
to March which means Jorgensen's claim
is that Mass Effect Andromeda will ship
at some point in the first three months
of 2017 if accurate then that would
represent a slight release delay
remember at e3 2015 when a Mass Effect
Andromeda reveal trailer stated that the
game's release date was set for holiday
2016 an interviewer asked speaking of
new IP is there any updated color you
can offer on the financial year 17
release date particularly with regards
to your non-sport franchises Jorgenson
responded yet we've got a great year
ahead for the first time I'm trying to
dampen down Wall Street expectations
which is a good position to be in we've
got our battlefield first-person shooter
coming in the third quarter and our
third-party titles at respawn built it's
called titanfall it's the second title
they brought out under that brand both
those are first-person shooter and will
be targeted around both fast action
driven shooter market as well as the
strategy driven market in the quarter we
have all our sports games we have
mirrors edge a runner game coming out in
the first quarter and then we have mass
effect which is a sci-fi action game in
our fourth quarter so big year ahead and
we're pretty excited details are thin on
the ground for Andromeda but trailers
have suggested that the game takes place
after the events of the original trilogy
as the legacy of Shepherd is mentioned
so what do you reckon can you hold out
just a little bit longer for some more
mass effect or do you want to play it
right out let me know in the comments
below or come find me on Twitter I'm at
Lucy James games for more on Mass Effect
keeping gamespot commander